why should kids worry about going to
university shouldn't we be looking at it
from a different angle no i think should
i think young children shouldn't
inspire
aspire to go to university and do great
things and this head of homework and i
think i can be a beacon that says come
to our college and be the best you can
be i mean i started as you know from a
council estate in leicester
and
did politics and and travelled the world
and now heading up this college means i
want others to be inspired you don't
have to go to university though to do
well do you no you don't i mean i didn't
i mean i was a cat mechanic
sold showers door to door a ticket out
in in the west end
but it's one of the roots it's not the
only route and i just think that um i
think if people can see it's an option
and it's a good option
and it doesn't matter where you're from
that i think you should have that chance
tell me about your uh beginnings i was
going to say humble beginnings but i
don't like it
i mean i remember we spoke in 2019
when i was when i was knighted
and back then i said it was bonkers for
a kid from my council estate to be
knighted and you know since then being
ennobled and now master of of homerton
even more crazier
but what it means is it means you know
if you work hard
if you find
find your yourself and your spirit and
your creativity great things can happen
but are you the exception that proves
the rule i think so and this is what i
want to change i want more pathways for
people like me black and white from
council estates
to have those pathways to success
pathways to do great things in business
in colleges
right across the board we've got to open
the pathways for them to be brilliant
but those kids have got to want want it
perhaps even more than kids from
privileged backgrounds
they do i mean i was hungry hungry for
success hungry to do things and kept
seeing barriers barriers all the time
it's in everyone what did you do about
them well i i bashed through them
climbed over yeah i mean i think you
have to be you have to be tenacious
but we need to take away those barriers
okay it's in everyone's interest
you know i when i joined the house of
lords i said in my maiden speech i think
there's
talent resides in every street
in every city in every corner of the
country
you know it's our job as
parliamentarians to open up those
channels open the pathways
and it's not that i win and and you lose
i win and we all win you know this
there's so much talent and i want to say
open up those pathways my lord what do
we do well i mean there's still
gross inequalities
race inequalities gender inequalities
you know i think the biggest challenge
these inequalities is denial of them
we've got to be big we've got to be bold
and say look
these are systemic problems let's be
honest
let's tear them down
let's
create pathways and inspire
inspire young men and women on council
estates to be in your job to be in my
job
and i think we all benefit from it well
i try and do my best i don't know if you
saw we were in wigan last week and we're
talking to youngsters in in primary
schools so it was really interesting to
hear what some of them had to say but um
what what's your advice to perhaps kids
who are watching this morning ahead of
going to school they well hopefully they
can their parents can buy my book
that is that is on sale from council
house to house of lords
and and if you're in a counselling state
and you feel that there isn't a there
isn't a big goal
i'm living proof
that working hard and being tenacious
and believing in yourself
that you can do great things then it's
my job as a head of hometown and a
parliamentarian
to tear down the barriers give you the
opportunities and then you run and
should it be weighted university
placings in in places like homington so
that kids from underprivileged
backgrounds have got more of a chance
well we need to widen participation we
need to recognize that a young kid from
maybe a disadvantaged background has to
work harder to get good grades we need
to recognize that and see the creativity
see the potential and then when they
come to places like homerton that we
have a wrap around support so they don't
feel an imposter syndrome
a sense of unbelonging i tell all my
students they belong
they need to own it they need to run
with it and i think that you know when
when you do that you see them glow you
see all the students black and white
we've got a black head he's telling me
to own the space
to be brilliant
and and i say to them it's not just
about academic success yes i want you to
be academically brilliant but i want you
to be a good citizen to do extraordinary
things and this is the message we keep
we keep pumping
at hamilton what would you have done
differently if you could have your time
again yeah well i'd do it quicker
i think
um but you know okay not always possible
it's not always possible i mean when you
interviewed me before i said to you that
i feel blessed you know i i was fostered
adopted i had two mothers
one black one white
both loved me
um and i took my opportunities
and i want to say to a world out there
that i hope you can and i want to make
it happen because i think we're a better
society for it
um
often i must you know i came from a
council of state as well and often i'm
asked about you know what advice i would
give to people and and i often say don't
don't carry the weight of what you're
under you being under privilege as a
child on your shoulder you know it's
done it's gone sure i agree with you i
mean i often say that it's not where you
start
but but it's where you go and even more
importantly how you go you know
integrity
uh morality your values
taking people with you
i mean you're inspired you know about
being here council house young girls
will say i want to be like kate
i want to be in the hot seat
and they see me at homerton
and i say the same i say the same thing
um yeah lots of the kids actually at the
school i said you want to do my job no
one of them wanted to be a carer
which was fantastic a lot of the guys
wanted to do the younger guys wanted to
do science but not much from the girls
on that okay no i think we've got to
reach out with stem learning
and the sciences and you know we need
formula one female engineers
in the paddock we've got to say this is
a job for you lewis wants you too
yeah and i think if we keep saying that
and showing that showing the the roots
the pathways to it i think we've got
half a chance but you know we've got to
be vigilant
because every time we think okay it's
done things are easier
and then you see you see as often
retreat
into our old ways with privilege with
race inequality with gender inequality
the the biggest challenge towards these
uh inequalities is denial of them
and i thought after black lives matter
for example i thought society was ready
for some of the biggest
perhaps most uncomfortable conversations
okay we've ever had and many did i know
sky did i was on some of those calls i
think skye's better for it actually but
then some retreated i think some in
government retreated into the old ways
saying it's not as bad as you think it
is and then you can't you can't deal
with it so you think the gains from
black lives matter are now receding i do
i do i think some have entrenched in
denial
worse still i think some are saying you
know those footballers that are taking
the knee is to the detriment of the
white working class
nothing could be further than the truth
that because we're dealing with racism
we can also deal with class poverty
with white working-class
inequality it's as i said it's not i win
you lose
let's be honest let's be bold
um let's give aspiration
to that generation
that feel alienated
and i just think in every walk of life
that that we can we can make things so
much better
that the starting point is honesty
and then drive
and then a plan
to deliver you talked about um your
maiden speech in the house of lords my
lord um did you did you have imposter
syndrome when you first went oh i did i
mean i mean you know it's like a gilded
a gilded chamber there's gold gold
everywhere lots of uh elderly white men
now now i'm on that trajectory
but i thought to myself do i belong to
to be fair to the lords they were very
gracious
many of them said you know can i help
and uh you know it takes years to
understand all of this although i will
say that a couple of times i was in the
library and i got a tap on the shoulder
from a fellow peer asking me to do the
photocopying no yeah yeah 100
actually three times
what did you say well the first time i
did it can you believe it i got up and
did it why did you i know
i know i defaulted
to okay all right all right is that
because you were embarrassed for that
yeah but a little bit
the second time i said i'm one of you
i'm up here showed him my badge
and he apologized
so you know sometimes change is not as
quick as we'd like
and sometimes you point the finger
other times you let it slide
but we want these institutions to
dramatically
change and give people like me a sense
of belong now now you can see me some of
the videos
on there i'm pointing the finger um you
know i own the space
when i'm there because i feel i have a
job to do
you know i share the lived experience
of many black and brown people in this
country and i think it's my role to talk
about that in the chamber
absolutely fascinating to hear from you
it's always good to talk to you thank
you very much